for our daily cancellation
on this monday we revisit the subject of
fat acceptance and body positivity
this is a topic which has popped up
several times during the segment
during this particular segment daily
cancellation you might even say that it
weighs heavily on my mind
what brings it up today are the slew of
articles preemptively condemning
anyone who shames anyone else over their
weight gain during the covet lockdowns
the media is anticipating that millions
of americans are going to emerge from
their cocoons this summer
like bulbous flightless butterflies
their time in lockdown having
transformed them from overweight to
even more overweight but we are warned
do not shame anyone for this it's not
their fault
the daily beast has an article from
elena um
demopolis that's how you pronounce the
last name it's titled
our bodies emerge from lockdown to a fat
shaming chorus
ignore it and she says quote if you want
to lose the quarantine 15 that's okay
and if you don't or can't that's okay
too
find the best way to exercise that works
for you
later in the article or an especially
revealing passage she quotes amy conway
who's the editor-in-chief of health
magazine
and she says quote a lot of people have
been sedentary and there are concerns
about going back to work
that might feel more winded going up a
flight of stairs
so moving your body throughout the day
is certainly something we'll encourage
it's not about how to lose the
quarantine 15 it's about making people
feel good
that's all that matters slate has a
similar diatribe this one titled
how to survive post-pandemic weight loss
pressure
the article written is written by a
rebecca onion
and now i'm not sure why the ladies of
the daily beasts and slate all have
names that sound made up but miss
onion lectures the reader not to post
about their workout routines or or their
weight loss strategies because
then your social media followers who
prefer to be lazy bastards my words not
hers
might feel bad and remember as we learn
from the daily beast this is all about
making people feel good that's all that
matters
by the way if you're wondering the
experts agree which experts
doesn't matter we've learned that too
the experts have spoken doesn't matter
you don't need to know the details but
the experts have said this the website
verywellhealth.com
has this headline quote experts stop
making people feel bad about covet
weight gain
we need the experts to tell us don't
make people feel bad uh this one is
written by carlo delgado who is at least
appears to be a real person based on her
name now i must admit off the bat
that i can't relate to any of this
content
um first of all i've personally been out
of lockdown since march
by that i mean march of 2020 i never
really entered into lockdown except to
the extent that i was forced to
when everything around me shut down but
even when everything was shut down
we were still very active in my family
more active than we'd ever been if
anything because there wasn't much else
to do besides run around outside go for
hikes go for walks and all that kind of
thing
that's why my wife and i both emerge
from this past year in very good
physical shape
now i realized that my bragging about my
own fitness
that by doing that i just did the very
thing that slate and the daily beast
warned me not to do
so why did i do it well because they
told me not to do it
and also because i'm not going to be
made to feel embarrassed and ashamed
of being physically healthy because
that's insane
you know in my life like most people
i've been out of shape and i've been in
shape
and i mean i'm always some kind of shape
just not one that i prefer all the time
and i always felt embarrassed about
being out of shape not about being in
shape
that's how it should be and why is it
because i was out of shape because i was
lazy it's embarrassing to be lazy
a person ought to be embarrassed by that
they shouldn't dwell in that
embarrassment they shouldn't stew in it
wallowing it
i'm not recommending depression and
self-loathing as a strategy i'm
recommending that people simply confront
the reality of their own personal
situation uh
admit that it's not ideal to be
overweight admit that they have control
over it
and then take control and change it
see the problem is that the the body
positivity mentality
precludes people from trying to change
the things they don't like about
themselves
and that fact points to the glaring
self-contradiction in this whole mindset
it's a contradiction that has of course
been evidence been in evidence for for a
long time long before the pandemic for
example
here's a clip from a show on the oprah
winfrey network it was it just went
viral over the past couple of weeks
but it originally aired i think in 2019
so here's an overweight woman
explaining how it's not her fault that
she's overweight because racism
did it to her let's watch you can't get
access to good healthcare good insurance
the research says that black women when
we do the same diets as white women
we lose less weight and we lose it
slower
even when we're following the diet than
our white women counterparts
and what and what public health
practitioners think is that our stress
responses
in the body change our metabolism
it's literally that the racism that
you're experiencing
and the struggle to make ends meet
actually means
the diet don't work for you the same
[Applause]
i mean we've made everything else racist
why not make carbs and calories racist
too
but whether racism is the lame excuse
for gaining weight or it's the pandemic
or whatever else we come up with so that
we can avoid going for a jog because
that's really what all this is about
um that the whole body positivity
movement is just
one long way around having to go for a
jog
but whatever the excuse is the fact is
that we're making excuses
okay and that's interesting isn't it
because we are both making excuses for
weight gain
and going to great lengths to make sure
that people don't feel bad about their
weight gain
and yet at the same time the body
positivity movement tells us that we
should be proud of our bodies
no matter their shape no matter how many
extra pounds of lard may be dropped
draped over them
we should celebrate our fatness not our
fitness
we're told so so then which is it
you know if you ought to be proud of
your fat body then
why are you making excuses for the fact
that it's fat it seems like an oddly
schizophrenic message
if you're declaring well fat is
beautiful i'm so proud of it
and also it isn't my fault that i'm like
this don't blame me
this is a case of having the cake and
eating it too which ironically is also
how you put the extra pounds on
point being you really have to choose
right
either obesity is a disease an
affliction something that has befallen
you by pure happenstance and misfortune
or it's something beautiful and powerful
and worth celebrating
it it can't really be both
i mean let's think of an example we
would all agree that bone cancer
for instance is an affliction a disease
a terrible misfortune
but we would also agree that that we
don't call it beautiful
we don't celebrate it neither would we
say that a person with cancer should be
ashamed obviously but we do recognize it
as a bad thing
and something that if we can we want to
stop
get rid of prevent ultimately we want to
cure it cancer is bad
we want to destroy cancer there's no
controversy about that
with obesity there should also be no
controversy it's a bad thing
in many cases it's a fatal thing we
should want to get rid of it
fortunately getting rid of obesity is a
thousand times easier than getting rid
of cancer
all you have to do in the majority of
cases is eat less and exercise more for
almost every overweight person on the
planet and throughout history
in almost every case that is enough to
solve the problem it is a very simple
solution i didn't say an easy
solution a simple one the only thing
that makes obesity confusing and
controversial
is that the body positivity movement
can't figure out its own position on the
subject
they want us to both pity the obese for
their obesity and also
celebrate the obese for their obesity
but you see a trait cannot be both
pitiful
and praiseworthy it can't be a disease
and beautiful what kind of thing is that
to say what is it a beautiful disease
you have to choose between the two it's
either beautiful or it's disease
we should either celebrate it or it's
not your fault it's a terrible thing
that happened to you
one or the other now personally between
the two options
um i would hope you choose the woe is me
it's not my fault it's because of racism
it's because of the pandemic approach
well you just heard there in the in the
in the video clip i'd prefer that
go with that because at least then
you're admitting that obesity is a bad
thing
a thing we should want to get rid of not
embrace
that's not much but it's a start we can
work with that
now it's just a matter of getting you to
accept a little bit of personal
accountability
and you can start by being accountable
for the fact that you are
today cancelled well i hope you enjoyed
that clip from the matt wall show if you
did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content